كنت في الثانية من عمري عندما سقط سايغون ،
قرر والداي أنه من أجل
البقاء على قيد الحياة وبناء المستقبل ،
كان علينا مغادرة البلاد
[موسيقى]
اعتاد الجميع دائمًا الاتصال بي بظل أمي ،
لم تستطع اتخاذ خطوة بدون
أن أكون هناك على
الأرجح  بدافع الشعور بالحاجة إلى
حمايتها
وأيضًا الشعور بعدم الرغبة في أن نتخلف
عن الركب في الليلة التي غادرناها ، تم نقلنا سريعًا
إلى
قارب الصيد الصغير هذا وكان هناك
مساحة أساسية لك للجلوس
وكان هناك
القليل جدًا  مساحة للتنقل ، كنت
سأمرض جدًا لدرجة أنهم وضعوني في
ثقوب الأسماك مما
زاد من سوء رائحة الأسماك في كل مكان
ووقود الديزل ،
كان هناك الكثير من عدم اليقين أيضًا مجرد
خوف كبير من الظلام
عندما لا يكون القمر خارجًا  أنت
تبتعد قليلاً دون أن
تعرف إلى أين نتجه ، كنا في
البحر
لمدة ستة أسابيع تقريبًا
، منحت أمريكا استثناءات
للاجئين الذين شردتهم الحرب ،
لذلك سُمح لنا
بدخول البلاد بناءً على هذا الاستثناء ،
فقد اتضح أنه  حياة صعبة حقًا
كان والدي
يكافح دائمًا لكسب ما يكفي من المال ،
وكان دائمًا غاضبًا
جدًا وغاضبًا أو منسحبًا عندما كان طفلاً ،
كان الأمر صعبًا حقًا لأننا لم نكن نعرف
سبب
غضبه طوال الوقت خلال الصيف
لم يكن هناك صيف  المخيمات بالنسبة لنا ،
سيتعين علينا الذهاب للعمل مع أحد
الوالدين أو الوالد الآخر الذي لديه أطفال
لي ، وأن
أكون قادرًا على تزويدهم بفرص أكثر بكثير
لم يكن لدي أي من ذلك ، فأنا أعتبر
نفسي مرافقي مرافقي مرافقي ، أنتم جميعًا  - أمي الأمريكية
وخلفيتي كلاجئ فيتنامي
هو الحلم الأمريكي النهائي الذي يتحقق
لأضع نفسي في حذاء والدي.
اترك بلدنا
لأن الحرية
والمستقبل هو ما يهمك
[موسيقى]